hello everyone welcome to rational
science the only side on the internet
that does physics rationally
everybody else does
mathematics they move Concepts around
I'm going to be answering some questions
at the end of the uh lecture
and we're going to have a lecture on
wave function including the wave
function collapse whatever those things
are but let's begin with some of the
subjects related to Extinction
and what is all that about well here we
argue that we are the last generation of
humans on Earth
and therefore we don't have too long to
go personally I doubt we'll never get
past the 21st century okay that's my
take on that I can't give you a date all
I'm saying is that when the global
um economy collapses it's not an if it's
a win
it's the end of man okay it's going to
be the collapse of the economy that's
going to kill us no uh asteroid no
diseases no climate change none of that
nonsense
the global economy will collapse when it
does not if but when it's the end of man
and that's a long story not gonna cover
that today but you can ask if you're
interested anyways a bit of news here
came out ah went on the other side give
me a second here
um
where'd he go
now here it is
and it says divers in Taiwan film rare
encounter with giant what doomsday fish
believed to be a harbinger of
earthquakes
um I don't know if it's our harbinger of
earthquakes I would say more or less
that it's uh Harbinger that we're the
last humans on Earth
uh you know uh if if there's a doomsday
fish uh someone prepared out there it's
got to do with us okay we're the last
humans on Earth so I don't know about
doomsday fish but uh it's a good
um
icon
uh you know pet
is it the
you know put on the milk cartons uh
saying that we're the last humans on
Earth
anyways uh here's another group and they
uh say that they're looking for
extraterrestrial intelligence I guess
they can't find it in Cambridge or in
Harvard and that's why they're looking
outside of the Earth but the issue here
is that these people say we have to
watch out
uh for what we stare out there because
we might find what we ain't looking for
in fact uh if the other folk discover
that we're spying on them and it turns
out that they didn't give us any
permission
to spy on them then uh in that case they
might get angry and colonize us and
treat us like Columbus treated the
Indians and here's a bit of news says uh
first contact with aliens could easily
end in genocide Scholars Warn and they
say this is probably the year of the
alien contact
and the reason they say that is that
there's some news lately on UFOs
unidentified flying objects right uh
President Biden gave orders to shoot
down three UFOs uh leaked footage from a
Navy pilot uh of a UFO that came out in
the news uh recently whistleblower's
report on U.S government cover-up about
UFO research and then a lot of people
claim that the United States agencies
some of them out there have collected
clandestinely uh some UFOs or parts or
whatever and so you constantly
constantly see this in the news lately
the question is if there's some uh
politics behind it you know
anyways uh what do these people say well
by the way this comes from the seti
research in Berkeley okay said he means
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
and investigators are they say are
virtually virtually mainly people from
science technology engineering and math
you know and there's few people from the
social sciences and they say if ever you
know you have the uh extraterrestrials
come over here uh the question is
whether you want to meet them with you
know military brass or whether you want
to meet them with
um some people with more social skills
we could say humanities
um anyway it says if humans are
perceived as disrespectful ET contact
could more likely lead to their
colonization of us and I think they're
thinking something along the lines of
Columbus there you see uh the uh on the
right hand side the ETS coming to visit
us backward folk right we're trying buy
them with uh some beads or whatever
and then uh there's an example there
where the Royal Society told James Cook
you know to avoid colonization and you
know hurting the natives that kind of
thing uh Royal Society being the
scientific ranch right uh but there were
private investors who had other ideas
and who funded the trip and they
suggested that maybe just maybe you know
they could uh conquer some of the land
out there
so uh the point is who do you want to
represent Earth would you want um
military business people who are the
ones who are running you know a lot of
this extraterrestrial rockets and so on
or do you want people like you know from
the humanities people that have more
social skills uh doing or entering at
least uh the business and being invited
so that they can
counsel from another point of view right
and the issue here is that I don't know
what all these people are up to but it
it's never going to happen we're never
going to see an alien an E.T right from
from outside the Earth here on Earth it
can't happen uh one because we're going
extinct but besides that it's impossible
for life for anything living to travel
interstellarly
okay so that's the argument we have here
and I've talked about that in the past
okay one fellow uh says the phone says
uh
you once uh replied to the assumption
that vaccines cause autism saying that
those espousingness are playing politics
the idea that autism is due to lack of
genetic diversity how is this not also
playing politics
well you know I
I Justified my stuff uh you know and I
don't think it's got anything to do with
politics okay here you see uh Calhoun's
mice and uh he built a uh an enclosure
and uh fed these mice everything they
wanted he started out with uh four
couples ended up with all those mice
that you see there
2200 I think was the
the highest number and towards the end
uh he created uh or mice were born that
were autistic and uh some of them were
homosexual I say that Calhoun created
homosexuality in the lab one of the
first ones if not the first one and you
know with animals so uh you know these
are things you got to look at and this
is not playing politics here you have uh
his results more or less
started out with four couples mice went
up to what was it about 2200 I think it
was 2000 thereabouts and then the colony
went down he started stopped reproducing
um
a lot of them lost interest in sex
uh they stopped um
having relations with the females the
females became aggressive
okay and um a lot of the
um mice that were born were born with uh
mental problems and so uh sounds like
you know the society we live in today
and that's more or less what Calhoun was
uh saying about this whole thing right
so uh you know that's not politics what
it is is I'm giving you some facts you
take them for what they what you want
but all I can tell you is
um that experiment reflects Humanity
quite well in the sense that we've moved
to the cities cities are Ultra crowded
and majority of the people have moved to
the cities and are in the process of
moving still further into the cities in
every country of the world
um when they get there they stop having
kids they go nuts they can't find jobs
they're excited right women are becoming
more masculine men are becoming more
feminine Etc you know so there's a lot
going on that uh at least for the
purposes of population it's a negative
Trend all those are negative Trends okay
and so that's essentially you know what
we refer to here what we're talking
about here
or someone says here it says loss of
genetic diversity is due to mixed
relationships among races
that's a catastrophe for Humanity okay
what can I tell you
um
uh maybe one of the questions I saw
should ask himself and anyone who thinks
like him is uh you know
have people who are white marrying white
yellow marrying yellow black marrying
black do they have problems even though
they've never mixed uh with any other
races
don't they have autism and uh genetic
diversity problems and all this other
stuff
I mean you know to say that this was
caused by mixture races sounds very
political and very little scientific
okay yeah you can hold any opinion you
want the issue is justifying it
okay uh one file says that on August 25
the EU shuts down the internet no joke
internet doomsday is coming digital
Service Act uh all opinions all channels
and sites that don't confirm to the
mainstream are censor that have to be
deleted free opinions no longer exist
okay thank God they give us a month to
get to reach there okay what does this
law say he said uh well I looked it up
digital markets uh act and it says the
new rules will also help protect users
from harmful and illegal content and
this comes from the European Parliament
by the way okay
so yeah they they are protecting you
okay they will significantly improve the
removal of illegal content okay so
you've got to watch out what kind of
content you put up there especially it
says it will also help tackle harmful
content which like political or health
related disinformation
political or health related
disinformation sounds like that fella
had the other day right David uh
whatever his last name was uh doesn't
have to be illegal and introduce better
rules for the protection of freedom of
speech so now these folks are protecting
your freedom of speech that's what
they're doing can't you see and uh so
they don't want you to disinform the
public on political or health related
issues okay so uh anything else you can
talk about why don't you talk about
Hollywood and the girls out there how
great they look you know talk about
stuff like that important stuff
don't talk about politics
and don't talk about you know uh health
issues especially about Kobe none of
that don't touch it I found out the hard
way you know they they gave me a another
strike but they gave me a warning
I had no clue whatsoever
okay uh finally it follows us with the
Oppenheimer movie coming out can you
explain nuclear weapons and what we are
told radiation is why are Nagasaki in
Hiroshima habitable
well
all I can tell you is my uh take on this
is I agree with the establishment of
quantum mechanics as far as you know
um The Chain Reaction okay uh one uh you
have the explosion essentially of the
uranium atom and uranium has what 92 uh
protons and electrons supposedly right
and 235 238
neutrons and think of it as 92 at least
92 or more hydrogen atoms stuff together
you know crunched together you know in
in a relatively small space obviously
it's the biggest atom and you're going
to break that apart and so that triggers
a chain reaction where it breaks other
atoms apart and other atoms apart and
it's a quick thing that happens there
and that part I have no problem with I
have problem with a part on the bottom
with the so-called radiation okay uh
they um
simulate it with waves and what are
waves uh vectors so you have all these
moving vectors what's a vector magnitude
and Direction officially right and I say
it's got no Direction but that's you're
up and for this discussion what you're
seeing there that thing that's moving
across all those so-called waves
transverse waves what you're looking at
is uh numbers that's what's moving and
so there's no such thing as a wave
especially a wave of numbers okay so
that's where they fail and they call
that radiation uh movement of numbers
and then the other one is uh particles
is way at the bottom there the red ones
right and those are not really particles
not in Quantum uh the quantum particle
is a number also you know it's not the
corpuscle the classical corpuscle so
what you're staring at there is a
one-way flow of vectors numbers and
particles which are also numbers values
uh you know they're talking about energy
bundles
they call them wave packets or energy
packets right and what is energy a
number
so the problem is they don't have a
physical interpretation and we're going
to be talking a little bit about that
today as well
uh so the difference there is that
radiation according to us is the
um torsion of physical objects that look
like a rope okay so it's a pair of twine
threads they throw in situ and that
torsion goes in both directions so uh we
have a different version of what
radiation is
and as far as uh Nagasaki you know the
uh the you know the Two Cities area in
uh Japan
uh you know why is it habitable well
here let me show you something these are
um some of the explosions we had on
Earth we had a few more obviously but
the first one was in 1945 and that was
Alamogordo in New Mexico there
and if you go by there like I have you
know I've gone through there
in fact more than once
and I don't think I have any radiation I
think I'm okay right and uh certainly
don't have cancer not yet at least uh
1979 we had three mile island disaster
in uh what was it Pennsylvania 1986
chernoville in Ukraine in 2011 Fukushima
in Japan
and these were close to small towns
and uh
people were evacuated immediately after
that after the explosions or the
accidents right and what happened after
that a lot of people came back many have
settled back close to
you know where where the uh accident
took place
and it didn't do anything to them you
know uh they they measure the radiation
I mean radiation doesn't last forever
this notion that people have that once
the bomb Falls the radiation lasts
forever no it dissipates eventually you
know it dies down
and so you can go and live back there
again there's no reason to think that
you know once the uh there's an accident
or a bomb is deliberately thrown that
you can no longer ever again live there
you know some people have moved back to
Fukushima and um to Chernobyl they say
that they uh you know re-uh uh you know
send people to some other cities or some
other City nearby but you know I have
doubts about that uh in great measure
because they mentioned a city that has
uh 25
000 26 000 inhabitants and Chernobyl had
48 and 49 almost 50 twice as much and so
I think some people live close to
Chernobyl again uh I just don't know you
know but I would think that uh it's not
a ghost town completely but for sure a
Three Mile Island uh nobody you know
left the country because of that and
same with uh fuku uh Huma there you know
it's
um these are accidents that happen and
um the radiation eventually dies down so
there's no reason not to live there okay
uh I think we should worry more about
um ever
some politicians out there deciding to
throw the bomb again
now that's something you should worry
about if uh if things
come to uh a point where a conventional
Weaponry doesn't do the trick they might
decide to press those red buttons you
know and uh
it's more than just a thread it could be
a reality and when that happens which
would be if it happened in that case
it's an if because it doesn't mean we're
we will throw those bombs right but if
that ever happens it's because the
global economy
is in big trouble so it's triggered by
the global economy competition among
countries Etc so it's part of the uh
theory that I have in other words I'm
saying global economy is going to cause
the extinction of man but that doesn't
rule out that at the last moment people
start pressing those red buttons
okay let's move on to
um
to the subject matter today which is
what it's the wave function okay now I I
need to give a little Preamble here uh a
little um introduction right and it's
that you know if you look at
mathematical physics today
it's in bad shape it's in bad shape
because you know people have reached a
point where they can't answer any
questions none and all they can say is
we're investigating we don't know but
we're investigating and uh That's so
exciting because science is like that
it's investigating forever and never
finding anything right the the idea is
to investigate only research you know
job security not to really find
and they can't find it's impossible for
them to find because they've gone off on
a tangent they're not doing physics
they're doing but asterism you know
instead of uh physics they're doing the
opposite exactly the opposite they're
working on abstractions and the question
is how did we end up like this well it
started with some of the uh people like
Galileo okay
um Galileo had a in his book he wrote
The Following he says philosophy meaning
um natural philosophy right that that's
what they called science in those days
is written in the Great Book whichever
is before our eyes I mean the universe
but we cannot understand it if we do not
first learn what the language and graphs
the symbols in which it is written which
is the book is written in mathematical
language
okay and then he goes on saying
mathematics is the language in which God
has written the universe and believe me
if I were again again be getting my
studies I should follow the advice of
Plato and start with mathematics and you
know he came at the heels of people who
were doing experiments like Gilbert and
Stevens and maletti
um people who had already done the
experiments that today we attribute to
him uh you know
throwing two weights and Discovery in
two different ways and discovering that
uh the lighter one does or the heavier
one doesn't reach the floor before the
lighter one okay and that was done by
Stebbins already in the 16th century
not 17 which is where he wrote this his
book uh Jolly little wrote his book it
already it happened in the 16th century
maletti talked about it in the 16th
century when uh Galileo was still uh
wearing uh you know shorts running the
streets as a boy
so um yeah they already had the idea of
experiments and then they started
putting math behind that and today we
have math and experiments and that's
more or less the notion that the
mathematicians have today they who call
themselves mathematical physicists
they're not physicist they're just
mathematicians with irrational
explanations for anything that's
invisible and intangible okay and uh so
what fellow kind of summarizes my way of
thinking here uh pretty he's pretty
close to how I think and he says the
following like I told you before Bill
physics is math ever since it's been
divorced from natural philosophy uh
physicist is not going to give you the
answers you're looking for because it
doesn't give a damn
it's sole purpose is to exploit and
reproduce natural phenomena for
technological purposes for its ultimate
goal of making money and win Nobel
prizes everything they do must have a
practical application okay experiments
right or nobody cares green Tyson Cox
Carol Kaku haven't done physics in
decades like you said they're clowns
yeah these people are more than uh uh
they're clowns in the sense that during
the entertainment business
they're not into physics or science
and here you have a uh an example uh
everybody knows uh Tyson there and he
puts out a
um a uh boat and just about everybody on
Earth quoted him you know repeated his
quote the universe is under no
obligation to make sense to you I mean
you know find hundreds of these and you
know they listen to this kind he what is
he saying he's saying look we don't
understand the universe that's
essentially what he's saying he's just
twisted around says hey father universe
doesn't have to speak the same language
you do
you know that's a way of twisting
uh the ignorance that he's uh confessing
there okay
and so you know you look up guys and you
look at what he does today and he's he's
in an entertainment business you would
think he's a physicist and he talks
about do we have free will
you know he's uh he's in uh subject
matter that you would say what does he
is he an expert on free will on religion
or any of that why is he talking about
free will when he should maybe be
talking about physics you know or if you
know how does a magnet attract another
stuff of that nature or even Cosmic
stuff and uh the question here is the
following you know these people will
tell you that when you say look how does
a magnet attract another
and they say well you know that's that's
not a question of physics the question
of philosophy
and why does this pencil fall to the
floor well that's the question
philosophy the mechanisms they say you
know the explanations the whys the
causes those are regarded as philosophy
but this fellow then goes in there and
talks about what free will
that's not philosophy
I mean you would think that you know
what's that got to do with physics okay
so if if that's part of physics if
that's part of what he can talk about
why doesn't he talk a little bit more
about mechanisms you know but no they
dismiss that as philosophy
okay and um
here's one guy that says it's
straightforward to you so that if you
have any doubts he'll tell you exactly
how much all these people know his name
is Sean Carroll and this he was uh
interviewing this is what he has to say
uh after a while right he says we just
don't know that's the best answer they
can give you and just in case you're
ready for another question he says Hey
so that is not a good question to ask
these are the exact words that come out
of his mouth say they don't know and
they don't want to answer certain
questions especially related to
explanations to mechanisms to wise to
causes they don't answer those questions
so the question is what do they know
and and they have this Duality or this
they cover both bases on the one hand
they say we don't know anything you know
don't ask us because we're still
researching and we don't know that
question don't ask that other question
blah blah blah and on the other hand
they say oh we know everything we've
proven everything we've proven quantum
mechanics uh We've proven general
relativity strength Theory and who knows
what else they've proven everything
they're proven big bang you can't even
contest that you uh they um they've
uh proven uh you know black holes Dark
Matter Dark Energy all has been proven
it's it's already settled and when you
ask them you know how does this word say
we don't know don't ask us uh we're
still investigating
so we have a contradiction because on
the one hand they say they know
everything on the other they say they
know nothing
okay and uh this is where the problem is
and the question is do they know
anything
okay this one so yeah this is uh what I
said the other day you know the circus
is in town all these people are clowns
they're stand-up comedians Vaudeville
comedians why because they're in the
entertainment business they don't know
anything about physics they cannot tell
you anything about physics and they get
millions of hits in all their videos and
uh you know they're very popular I'm
sure they get a lot of money for what
they do they're called to give talks Etc
and what do they talk about all they can
tell you is that they don't know
and so why did you pay you know whatever
50 bucks to go see them just for the uh
celebrity issue you know so no none of
these guys know anything and so you're
wasting your time when you when you go
and visit them whether you visit them in
person or you watch their videos or
interviews or whatever or a show where
where they're in
you know these people don't know
anything especially they don't know
anything about science but a lot of
people have this idea that you know
they're getting their shot of science
for the week oh I'm going to listen to
Brian Greene or Brian Cox or you know uh
Tyson or or who knows and and they think
they're getting their shot of uh science
they sign them they
um you know they follow these guys and
it turns out all they're given is
nonsense these people cannot talk to the
public
about math they cannot go in there and
and begin talking about equations
because people will just leave so they
have to kind of translate the equations
to what people might understand but when
they translate they only translate
nonsense which is the only part that
they can talk about it on TV or in
movies or wherever in interviews they
can only talk about the physical
interpretation
okay of their equation
because you know otherwise people will
be turned off they don't understand all
those equations
so they give you the most irrational
thing they can
give you
they ask you that doesn't make sense
yeah we don't understand it either
foreign
so what have you learned listening to
those people you know it's like you you
grow Dumber by the second and for every
word that comes out of their mouth
and uh so yeah we have some people who
are questioning some of these things and
they say the following says looks like
we are at the end of physics
and other fellow says there
um he says the next few years may tell
us whether we'll be facing questions
that we cannot answer everybody is uh
more or less or not everybody but a lot
of people are coming to their sense and
say Hey you know something wrong is it
the end of physics and the answer is no
it's not the end of physics okay let's
let's get that right it's the end of
mathematical physics okay mathematical
physics is not physics it's the end of
mathematical physics because with all
the equations all the experiments all
the measurements that they have done in
at least in the last hundred years if
not the last 400 years since the
so-called Scientific Revolution
um you know we made no progress
these people don't know what electricity
is they say it's a flow of beads
but what are they using the planetary
model of the atom which they deny they
say well that's something Boris model is
not true
uh they don't know what magnetism is
they don't know how a magnet attracts
another they can't tell you how gravity
works you know the simple thing you know
my my great experiment you know we have
a pencil very important thing very
always doing in the presence of it
relativist right never do it on your own
okay you let go of the pencil and it
always falls to the floor okay
hahaha and uh they cannot explain why a
pencil falls to the floor they go
through this whole thing where you know
they have to bend space time and time
you know they Bend time like if that's a
mechanism a physical interpretation
so yeah they have no answers for
anything that is invisible and
intangible that's what they haven't
figured out and what they haven't really
figured out is they have to
uh you know imagine what is what Mother
Nature is using as a mediator that never
crossed their mind
they think that because you know they
can't see or touch something underneath
a pencil or above the pencil that
there's nothing there and so they go
into concept and say well it was mass it
was gravity it was energy force
you know time
okay so uh let's find out
um what this wave function is let's
start with some definitions and a good
way of looking at this is through the
universal movie you know I like to do it
through the universal movie
um what is the universal movie real
quickly uh every frame represents
location location of every atom in the
universe therefore there's nothing
moving within any frame if you want to
see something movie moving you will have
to use at least two frames that means uh
the ones on the bottom for example are
those that require at least two frames
the ones on the top the concepts here or
objects right they only require one
frame of the film it's like if you had
God's camera you took a picture a 3D
picture right and that's what you put in
a single frame everything's just
standing still at a given distance from
everything else okay that's it and where
do we put the wave
well wave is not a physical object it's
not a thing we cannot put it on the top
We cannot put wave in a single frame of
the movie wave requires at least two uh
uh two frames partly because it's made
of what two Fields okay you have the
electric field and the magnetic field
and here we're talking about the uh
light waves right wave of light right
electromagnetic waves so you have
electricity and and or electric field
and magnetic field you need two waves
and then just in case you have to put
you know uh if you're gonna put the wave
you're gonna need at least two frames
it's going to stretch across two frames
you cannot have the word wave in a
single frame okay so that's that's what
the problem is you know so wave is a
dynamic concept and it's not a physical
entity which is what mathematical
physics uses it as okay they use it as
as if it were a physical object
and that's where they fail okay so you
cannot say that the wave did this the
wave did that
because wave is not a thing
okay you cannot use it as a noun in
physics okay you can say the flag wave
you can say the water wave you cannot
say that the wave waved okay wave is a
verb it's not a thing okay okay so
that's the wave how about the function
you know it's remember we're talking
about wave function here's a function
function is essentially a um an equation
even though there's a little bit of a
difference if you look at a function
versus an equation you can see that are
just slight differences two or more
variables is what a function has uh you
don't need variables in the case of
equations and you can write the function
as an equation right
and the equation may or may not be a
function necessarily okay so you have
these couple differences between them
but essentially you can think of a a
function as an equation okay for all
practical purposes it's just the fine
print okay so there you have a function
uh why did I put it on the bottom
because a function
an equation represents motion always
okay always is uh you know it's uh what
it is okay a function that represents
motion uh the way you do motion is you
have to replace values inside the
variables okay so you have a variable
you replace that with numbers
and for every number you put in you get
a result and you plot those results and
then you have your emotion you have the
universal frame a universal movie with
each frame representing a single you
know location essentially that's what
you get so function is dynamic wave is
dynamic so we have a wave function what
do you think it is it's a dynamic
concept it's not a physical object
guess what uh they treat us a physical
object wave function is like a
standalone thing that's the way they
look at it
and um here you have uh the source of
the wave function it's uh Mr Schrodinger
Irvin Schrodinger and it looks like that
thing up there okay and what does it
represent you know we're not here to do
math we're here just to say that you
know you can calculate the probability
of finding a Quantum particle in a given
state by treating it as a what a wave
function okay so all you got to do is
replace some of those variables there
and you'll have your wave function
okay great so uh
what does that wave equation do for us
apparently it's it just describes you
could say motion that's all that's what
we're doing there okay nothing more than
that
okay so this is what it looks like once
you uh put it in motion okay this can be
the wave function in motion this is the
universal
wave function motion okay it looks
something like this okay
you can see it there it's uh like a
little snake rolling around a wire a
pipe okay that's what it looks like
um I prefer to look at it a little
differently and more or less like that
you know that's what they're talking
about when they're saying the universal
wave function okay I mean you would
think that this wave function covers the
entire universe right because this is
what they're referring to they're saying
the wave function is the entire universe
in fact
um uh here you have uh one fellow who
put them together
his name is uh Roger Penrose and he made
the wave packet he puts that in his book
he illustrates it like that like you see
it there and I guess it's it comes from
uh the wave and the packet you know they
put them together and that's more or
less what Schrodinger worked with to get
his notion of the wave equation or the
you know the
universal wave function okay
in those days I think they just applied
it to the particles to a given particle
but today they have extrapolated to the
uni whole universe and here you have one
guy who vouches for that okay he'll tell
it to you in his own words okay here's
uh Sean Carroll and he says the universe
is a quantum mechanical wave function
and that is all that exists uh-huh
he was interviewed by closer to truth
fellow okay the same Quantum thing can
be sliced in different ways to give
different objects tables and chairs and
peoples and planets okay so we have a
single wave function a universal wave
function you slice it in different ways
to give it all these objects that we can
see and touch on every you know here on
Earth okay great so the uh interviewer
asks what does the that literally mean
yeah I mean what have you said a Quantum
waveform of the universe is it one big
thing that describes everything or is it
one big thing that has little Quantum
waveforms that comes out of it you know
there is is it chopped into pieces or is
it a single thing made of a single piece
or whatever you can chop this thing into
pieces
and the answer is it's both
that's the kind of answers of
mathematical physics it would give you
right uh it's both it's both at once
that's the miracle of applying quantum
mechanics even you know it comes on top
and you say hey that's a miracle Quantum
mechanic you know one of the things that
makes it difficult to understand
aren't separate Quantum wave functions
for different parts of the universe in
quantum mechanics there is not a wave
function of the baseball and a wave
function of the back there's a wave
function for the baseball plus bat
system in fact there is one-way function
for the entire universe all at once
so how does he uh you know reconcile
this with uh tables chairs peoples and
Planet I mean here you have
um a little bit of a problem because he
says there's a single wave function and
then he says that you can break it up
into little pieces so which is it a or b
and again he says it's both okay and
so what have you learned nothing
absolutely nothing from from this fellow
and here you see he continues he says
what really is happening is this
abstract mathematical thing the wave
function uh-huh yeah it's a happening of
this thing he calls it but it's a
mathematical thing and it's an abstract
mathematical thing the wave function
okay what is he talking about
and he says we even have a name for
where the wave function lives
so not only do we have a thing but it
lives somewhere it lives in a space
called Hilbert space Hilbert space is
just an enormous space of possible wave
functions oh man we're we're learning so
much from this guy okay
says a wave function just evolves in
Hilbert's space that's all there is this
wave function evolving in time there's
no extra explanatory level so don't ex
don't expect the physical interpretation
beyond that he's told you everything he
knows okay and uh when we talk about
reasons and causes and explanations you
know which is what physics wants to know
uh laymen also want to know that these
are ancient words that we repurpose
maybe they just don't apply in modern
quantum mechanics yeah they don't apply
because uh not a single person in
quantum mechanics can explain reason uh
causes reasons don't belong to a physics
but causes mechanisms that's what they
cannot explain and so why because
they've never figured out the invisible
stuff that mother nature uses as
mediators that's the problem they've
always used particles and they convert
the particle into a number so we don't
even have particles anymore corpuscles
you know classical corpuscles they they
illustrate a little dot uh corpuscle but
when you put them against the wall they
say oh but we don't mean that what
you're looking at is a bundle of energy
and what is energy a number
it was a unit right okay well he should
have paid attention to another fellow
known as Richard Feynman and he would
have listened to Richard Feynman he
wouldn't be saying nonsense today here's
Richard he says you think I'm going to
explain it to you so you can understand
it he was talking to students no you're
not going to be able to understand it
you see my physics students don't
understand it either that is because I
don't understand it nobody does while I
am describing to you how nature works
you won't understand why nature works
that way and then in another class you
set the volume which I think is even
more famous
he says I think I can safely say that
nobody understands quantum mechanics do
not keep asking yourself if you can
possibly avoid it how but how can it be
like that nobody knows how they can be
like that the more you see how strangely
nature behaves the harder it is to make
a model that explains how even the
simplest phenomena actually worked so
theoretical physics has given up on that
okay so what's the issue the issue is uh
quantum mechanics or you can say
mathematical physics and mathematical
physicists they've given up on giving
you explanations physical
interpretations they've dismissed that
now as philosophy they say well that's
that's just philosophy ontology you know
word salad
uh semantics right they don't care about
any of that they care about what what
was uh Tyson about Free Will that's the
stuff you know and this guy also talks
about how the brain works how did Roger
Penrose by the way they they went into
philosophy what is known as philosophy
you know
um why you think the way you think you
know this kind of stuff which has very
little to do with physics
proper right okay
so we're in the wrong subject matter
with quantum mechanics and with
mathematical fists completely you know
all around
um
here is uh what the uh what they do with
the wave they say that if you observe
the wave this uh this great wave
function right
um if You observe it it collapses
collapses to a point essentially so it's
spread out when it's not observed and
when it's observed or touched or
whatever it collapses okay to a point
and so I'd like to illustrate a little
differently you know here you have uh
you're gonna be
um sticking your hand where the wave is
rolling and suddenly when you go and
touch it it turns into a ball that's
essentially what Quantum is saying uh
they never explain the mechanism they
just say this is so we proved it it's a
done deal and we cannot explain it of
course they cannot explain it because
they're doing more magic than than the
Bible I mean here you're talking about
not Jesus walking on water or going to
heaven and coming back and after three
days none of that stuff that's easy
stuff but this stuff you know it's it's
even unimaginable you cannot imagine
this stuff they're saying that here you
have a you know a wave which is vectors
Right Moving vectors which is already
irrational and as soon as you touch
those vectors it turns into a ball
and the ball is not a ball because it's
a Quantum uh number it's a value so all
they did was transform you know vectors
into a single value what does that mean
what does that what what does that have
to do with physics that's the question
has nothing to do with physics certainly
nobody cares about that stuff people
want to know why a pencil fossil floor
how a magnet attracts another and what
is electricity how does the atom really
work what does it look like
okay that's what the people want to know
okay so here's the universal wave
function and this is what happens when
it collapses here you'll see it in a
second here's the wave function
universal one right and suddenly you
know it goes in there in Kaboom and
collapses to a point
so that's what we have and so the
question is whether you know this is uh
more or less what uh we saw the other
day with a two black holes rolling
around each other you know it's moving
all those waves that they claim they've
uh were able to sense you know detect
and the question is uh is that the wave
function that they're moving there is
that are those ripples along the wave
function is that the material that is
waving the wave function
so uh yeah we have a big problem because
we reached after 100 Years of quantum
mechanics and relativity
if you were 11 50 years maybe of or less
than uh String Theory right
um what do they know what do these
people know what are they talking about
they're talking about wave function that
the Universe the entire universe is no
longer space and stars you know and
planets and that guys I know it's a wave
function
and uh there are localized I guess wave
functions
turn into planets stars and whatever
and these people say well you know
that's just an interpretation because
it's really a single wave function for
the whole universe then they tell you
the wave function can collapse if You
observe or touch it right see your touch
right and so here's the universal wave
function it's a single wave function I
hope it doesn't collapse every time I
move you know I touch something I see
something the entire universe collapses
the wave function of the whole universe
collapses what sense does any of that
make anymore
I mean these people were completely out
of it that's why they had to get into
what in the end into the entertainment
business that's why they had to be
clowns because they're interested in
making money saying look I studied 10
years math at the University I want to
make money off of this and they can't
make money explaining how the universe
works so they don't do science or
physics what they do is they say uh let
me tell you what we understand and we
don't understand anything but this is
what we understand and that we have
proven and they talk about black holes
dark matter you know Big Bang all that
stuff particle being at two places at
once you know the good stuff
entanglement this particle affects that
one by managing instantaneously all that
good stuff and then they tell you all
this stuff and you say but all that is
irrational yeah we don't understand it
either but we've proven it that's
important we've proven it
okay so yeah what can we say
here's some of the issues that people
ask questions uh comments people made
I'm gonna start with uh one thing I was
looking at the other day and it says
they have a black hole laboratory at
Nottingham University that's where Robin
Hood went okay Nottingham University and
so today they have a black hole
laboratory I was I was really stunned by
that they they even have a special place
or black holes okay maybe it's that
Hilbert space that's in there I don't
know the black hole is occupying somehow
okay and follow says says the universe
is both one Universe multi one universe
multi-dimensional
uh well yeah they like to cover all
bases see uh you gotta do a little
better than that um I explained the
other day that you know you could have
uh all the galaxies in the universe uh
they could form a single Universe
because they all share the same space
the question is whether there's another
group
that is separated from our group and
we'll call that temporarily we'll call
that a second Universe a parallel
universe Another Universe the problem
with that idea is that you cannot
separate
one Universe from the other because you
cannot put a fence to space that's where
the problem is
you know
for example here you have uh the
multi-universe right all those W Maps
there okay so uh one our universe is one
of those right and there's all these
other universes what's the problem the
problem that each one of those universes
contains the black stuff that you see
there contains space and it's the same
space as ours
in other words
um you cannot put a fence around space
and separate it from that other universe
so the question is you know uh Universe
there's only one because space cannot
can you cannot put a fence to space and
somehow separate it from Another
Universe all matter in the universe
shares the same space now could there be
a different clump of matter separate
from the clump of matter where our
galaxies and stars and everything here
uh is yeah that could be so but then we
can't call that a universe we would have
to you invent a new word such as Clump
or or whatever that's the one I use
clump of matter because that's what it
is
okay so yeah there's only one Universe
uh but not multi-universes
multi-universe is no maybe multi-clumps
that could be it okay okay
uh another person says what if God is
Universe himself
okay why cannot Universe be infinite and
eternal
well first of all I think God uh would
like to commit suicide or maybe has
already you know I don't think he wants
to live forever
it's the worst punishment someone can
have you know imagine living forever not
being able to die you know that's got to
be terrible
um I think it's a curse not a blessing I
mean be nice to live maybe 200 500 years
that's fine but to live forever and not
be able to die killing yourself stabbing
yourself poisoning yourself
yeah so God probably committed suicide
by now but the question here is that you
know I haven't answered the question you
said
um
if God is Universe you know if God is
everything which is the word that people
use for Universe if God is everything
then God is nothing as well you know
what do you mean by God is Universe okay
and then uh the words infinite and
eternal are usually used to stop any
questions because you say well I don't
know because he's an infinite and
eternal and we have no clue what that is
so it's a way of stopping questions
whenever you use the word infinite or
Eternal or forever any of those so you
know all you're doing is avoiding
answering the question you say I'm not
going to deal with the question now this
is what I believe in this at the end of
the discussion that's all you're saying
okay you're not investigating to find
out what this universe could be or what
you know what it uh how it works or
whatever right
this is the issue you got to really
tackle and not run away and when people
talk about Infinities and Eternity
they're running away
unless you're talking about whether the
universe itself is
eternal which it is obviously but uh
that's just an issue of
of matter not being able to convert into
space or space converting into matter
that makes it eternal
okay if I was says I called the black
stuff hyperspace
well you can call the black stuff there
you know them where the stars are or
anything you want you can call it
Charlie if you want I mean the question
is what is the green stuff if uh space
or what you call it hyperspace okay so
it's hyperspace no problem we'll call it
hyper space if you like that word better
so the black stuff there with all the
little stars you know that's hyperspace
and uh and so the question can you put a
fence around hyperspace and if so what's
outside what's the green stuff that's
what we want to know so anyone who
proposes anything other than space right
he wants to call it hyperspace okay you
can call it Charlie you haven't said
anything you just named it you know the
question is is there something outside
of space is space a physical object does
it have a border okay if so what's
outside of it what's the green stuff can
you put a fence around space
okay so this is these are the issues
that people uh do not answer they they
elude them they start putting names
there you know saying I gave it a name
hyperspace okay great so we call it
hyperspace now to make them happy and we
have a flat earther okay it says taking
the fact that since I was six the idea
of outer space has been force-fed to me
and many around the world why talk about
these Concepts that children as young as
six
you want to educate them I guess right
why show a globe in the background of
every TV show episode of movie why use
the word globe in everyday conversations
on TV and articles I guess you figured
out where he's coming from though
I and many have never been to outer
space okay
neither have I okay without visible
spectrum of light in free space of the
wandering stars planets and the Sun then
how can we assume outer space ever
existed
well you don't have to assume you have
to define the word exist and then you'll
know whether space exists or not right
and you've got to define space as well
and so you just got to Define these
words you know you want to know whether
God exists it's a cinch very easy you
just Define the word exist
and then we'll know if God meets the
definition or not if God meets the
definition and he exists if he doesn't
he doesn't exist that's how simple it is
so if you want to know space exists very
simple you know Define exists and then
define space or point to it or whatever
right and then uh if space meets the
definition of the word exist it exists
by definition see how easy it is so it's
not a question of belief it's not a
question of you know uh saying I'm going
to memorize this or anything like that
it's just a question of definitions
the AFL says can you please define your
concept of Separation because we say
distance is separation right and you
know I don't know if this was uh just an
extreme Devil's Advocate a lot of people
do that you know and nothing wrong with
that except that you know when they go
off on a tangent they're just uh you
know getting entangled by themselves
don't uh Define every word in uh we
don't we don't Define every word in
science okay and uh for this purpose uh
for separation ordinary speech will do
just a notion what are we talking about
separation not occupying the same exact
volume that's the notion okay that we
have of what of what separation is so
you don't need a fancy definition for
the word separation separation is what
you learn when you were a kid I don't
think you need a a super duper uh
definition for the word separation
everybody understands separation because
we're the same it's just whatever word
whatever notion we have out there of in
ordinary speech uh we I don't think we
need a scientific definition of the word
separation
and distance separation means you know
they don't occupy the same volume maybe
that's a definition that you can use but
that's the notion and so I'm not sure
why people raise questions other than
you know extreme Devil's advocacy okay
okay and here we have another felony he
says the following he says um is this
the amount of torsion is it just the
amount of torsion applied to the Rope
between two atoms that uh explains the
various spectrum of radiation light or
does the length of Any Given rope
between atoms also play a role in
determining light Spectra
and yeah uh here I can show you uh
with a graph what were you referring to
okay here's a visible spectrum you can
see it's a small portion of the entire
Spectrum right there at the top in the
middle okay so that's the one in color
that's the how thin the visible spectrum
is of light and there you have it
expanded it's zoomed in and you can see
that we have the red to the Violet okay
infrared to ultraviolet
and the question here is you know where
are we going to simulate light with
uh and you know quantum mechanics likes
to simulate it with balls you know a
little points dots circles whatever and
uh
they call them wave packets sometimes
they just say it's a photon and the
photon stands for a classical corpuscle
in the eyes of many and then they
clarify no it's not a classical Corpus
so what we're talking about is a number
a value energy a packet of energy a ball
of energy
so they go back and forth and you never
learned you know what a photon is is it
a particle or ain't it you know which
which is it and of course they'll never
clarify that they also simulate it with
waves and we discussed that a little bit
uh what you're looking at is vectors
okay and they draw that ridiculous thing
called a transverse wave electromagnetic
transfers wave and what the what what
you're seeing there is just vectors and
they call them Fields field what are
Fields well two Fields make a
electromagnetic uh light
electromagnetism so neither the balls
nor the wave their uh represent physics
they have nothing to do with physics
because neither of those
are objects you know they don't stand in
for objects the object is the one on the
bottom and it looks like a rope more or
less and what we're looking at there is
a um two twine threads and where the
um uh links are wide you know
or longer you have
you're in the red side of the spectrum
whereas where they're very close
together where you have very short links
you get into the Violet region and
that's the way it goes essentially all
the way to gamma rays to radio waves you
know that whole Spectrum you can look at
it in the same way longer wavelengths
you go to the left shorter wavelength
you go to the right okay and what's
important about uh this is the following
let me show you another graph that
synthesizes this okay keep that one in
mind completely let me get rid of this
one
and this is what it looks like okay you
have C equals frequency times wavelength
that is the equation of a rope okay
because frequency is the number of links
and wavelength is the link the link
length Okay the link of a link
and you can see there
um you know you take any rope like a
two-strand rope right like this one here
let me see if I can move this out for a
second
and because it's better maybe to see it
here and here you see you know if you
torque the Rope the links become shorter
and there are more links and if you
untuck the Rope you know for the same
amount of rope right you have uh longer
links and you have fewer links
okay and so that's essentially what C
equals frequency times wavelength
represents it it's that is the equation
of a rope you know which is torque which
is moving around okay so uh you know C
equals frequency times wavelength C
being 300 000 kilometers per second
which is the speed of light is equal to
you know the inverse relation between
frequency and wavelength you raise one
you lower the other that is the equation
of a rope it's not an equation of
particles it's not an equation of waves
and light travels both directions
because of a robe not as it is in
quantum mechanics in One Direction You
Know It's Just unidirectional the reason
you see me in ICU at the same time is we
are connected by the same ropes every
one of our atoms in our body
and with